but talking to people that you work with
you always that you are known as this
kind of the positive force on set we can
do this the kind of yeah we can do this
it is it true that Emily Blunt did break
your spirit it was a potato very hot and
we were the dropship no she didn't break
my spirit but there was that moment yeah
we basically were in this drop ships I
don't know if you guys if you've seen
the trailer
we're being dropped out of this ship in
our exosuits and it was a tiny set they
made the set really smaller is kind of
like as big as a sardine can and we're
all in there it's so hot in there
there's no air in there camera crew like
bumping into us and we're hanging in the
exosuits in harnesses so like the entire
weight of you and your suit is like on
your groin Olympian mixed report people
is just like hanging like this just
waiting and Tom and that insatiable
positivity I can just see it's just
starting to unwrap he was pouring with
sweat I remember looking at him and he
was like guys please please roll and I
just looked at him and I just went this
sucks like that and he looked at me he
goes it's a challenge because you know
what if I start complaining it's on they
start going down it's on and I went Tom
it sucks
if you don't let the girl go alright
we'll track you down all right we'll
find you all right we'll kill you